Meza anime like I still think meta anime
peaked with monogatari intended like
light novel light novel shows
adaptations it kind of like Pete we've
won a Qatari and there's been other good
light novel shows as well I've been
better but I'd say you know Hera he
really was the first time I notice it
Harry it was Harry he and Loki star and
then monogatari was the one that came
afterwards and then it kind of like
nothing out did it and now and now you
see a lot of lazy [ __ ] attempts a
meta humor and meta jokes like there was
what one and one anime I saw recently
which was like such an eye rolling
moment is the the milfy Sakai for ads
last year okay okay because it was you
know everyone thought and you know it
kind of marketed itself as like a parody
of the easy right because it's like oh
it's the East Lake High genre but you
know there's a mom this time and I you
gotta eat it's different it's different
because there's a mom this time and I
remember there was one joke okay they're
in like they're at they were in a hot
springs right and this is one cinder day
that's in the hot springs and then she
like she like stands up and she's naked
in front of the main character yeah and
then the main character literally says
ah this is the scene where you're about
to hit me right and there goes our but
how about if I don't hit you I bet you
weren't expecting that were you and the
main character goes ah you're right I
wasn't expecting that and the cinder a
just goes off crying and that was the
joke wow that was the joke I remember I
remember we have this exact same
conversation that is the Chi Tila's
video you're like [ __ ] lights fuming
a white this is not how you write a
message ugh you basically explained the
mentor before you told the mentor first
of all I want all my animations acted
out by gone like that yeah
second of all I just like where as you
said you tend to watch the trash Lisa
Chi I could give a less of a [ __ ] about
the East Coast gap right there
it's so like it's aged it iterates on
itself and then changes one thing it's
like yeah it's like I'm wouldn't be
surprised this is another slime one
except he's like a green slime next
right it's just like that's gonna be the
next base just season two yes the green
it's just like I I just I just struggle
to give a [ __ ] about any of the Easter
kinda come like I wanted to watch the
mum want just for the memes yeah I
couldn't even muster up to like tighten
up in yes it wasn't even that good for
the memes like it was it was it was you
saw the title you're like haha I can
make him email this and if I did yeah
and then I watched two episodes I'm like
now I'm done because I won't watch these
shows so I can talk about them but then
I realized like if I now maybe I don't
even know that six months after that
shows aired that that meme is long dead
and no one no one's gonna mention it's
like by the time the next season comes
around three months time no one's
[ __ ] and then maybe it'll be like a
factoid one day George some mommy's okay
yeah